in your local theaters this week can
find the story of a young man who
challenged a small town that forbids
dancing and the film called Footloose
and a movie about a mermaid who comes to
the big city called splash with the
leading characters together as we have
tonight and they become a handsome
combination called mr. Kevin Bacon and
as Daryl Hannah
there are two films nominated in the
interesting category of sound effects
editing
they are both adventure stories of space
travel and danger one is based in truth
one in fantasy but their sound effects
are equally realistic the nominees are
Ben Burtt for a Return of the Jedi Jay
buckle Hyde for the right stuff
the winner is winner is Jay buckle I for
the right stuff
really nervous I'd like to thank my wife
Beth my daughter Julia for putting up
with us business I would like to thank
the Academy for voting this to me I'd
like to thank Phil Kaufman for having
the vision to make the right stuff the
way it is I'd like to thank bob charde
often Irwin Winkler and Gareth Wiggin
for giving him the support he needed to
make it I'd like to I'd like to thank
the 40 or so people who worked with me
on the sound of the right stuff I'd like
actually quickly to go through a couple
of you don't mind Tim Holland at Jackson
Karen Wilson John Benson the editors the
assistants I like finally to thank a few
people who brought me into the business
Jerry greenberg les Hobson Walter Murch
Francis Coppola thank you all good
evening